we now move to a new topic conditioning
every probabilistic concept or
probabilistic fact has a conditional
counterpart as we have seen before we
can start with a probabilistic model and
some initial probabilities but then if
we are told that a certain event has
occurred we can revise our model and
consider conditional probabilities that
take into account the available
information but as a consequence the
probabilities associated with any given
random variable will also have to be
revised so a PMF will have to be changed
to a conditional pmf let us see what is
involved consider a random variable X
with some given PMF whose values of
course sum to 1 as must be true for any
valid PMF we are then told that a
certain event a has occurred in that
case the event that X is equal to little
X we will now have a conditional
probability of this form we will use
this notation here to denote the
conditional probability that the random
variable takes the value little X notice
that the subscripts
are used to indicate what we're talking
about in this case we're talking about
the random variable X in a model where
event a is known to have occurred of
course for this conditional probability
to be well-defined we will have to
assume that the probability of a is
positive this conditional pmf is like an
ordinary PMF except that it applies to a
new or revised conditional model as such
its entries must also sum to 1 now the
random variable X has a certain mean
expected value which is defined the
usual way in the conditional model the
random variable X will also have a mean
it is called the conditional mean or the
conditional expectation and it is
defined the same way as in the original
case except that now the calculation
involves the conditional probabilities
or the conditional pmf finally as we
discussed some time ago a conditional
probability model is just another
probability model except that it applies
to a new situation so any fact about
probability models any theorem that we
derive must remain true in the
conditional model as well as an example
the expected value rule will have to
remain true in the conditional model
except that of course in the conditional
model we will have to use the
conditional probabilities instead of the
original probabilities so to summarize
conditional models and conditional pmfs
are just like ordinary models and
ordinary pmf's except that probabilities
are replaced throughout by conditional
probabilities let us now look at an
example consider a random variable which
in this case is uniform takes values
from 1 up to 4 so each one of the
possible values has probability 1 over 4
for this random variable we can
calculate the expected value which by
symmetry is going to be the midpoint so
it is equal to 2 and 1/2 we can also
calculate the variance and here we can
apply the formula that we have derived
earlier 1/2 times B minus a times B
minus a plus 2 and in this case it's 1
over 12 times B minus a is 4 minus 1
which is 3 and the next term is 5 and
after we simplify this is 5 over 4
suppose that now somebody tells us that
event a has occurred where event a is
that the random
variable X takes values in the range 2 3
4 what happens now what is the
conditional pmf in the conditional model
we're told that the value of one did not
occur so this probability is going to be
0 the other three values are still
possible what are their conditional
probabilities well these three values
had equal probabilities in the original
model so they should have equal
probabilities in the conditional model
as well and in order for probabilities
to sum to one of course these
probabilities will have to be 1/3 so
this is the conditional PMF of a random
variable given this new or additional
information about the outcome the
expected value of the random variable X
in the conditional universe that is the
conditional expectation is just the
ordinary expectation but applied to the
conditional model in this conditional
model by symmetry the expected value
will have to be 3 the midpoint of the
distribution and we can also calculate
the conditional variance this is a
notation that we have not yet defined
but at this point it should be
self-explanatory it is just the variance
of X but calculated in a conditional
model using conditional probabilities we
can calculate these variants using 1
tsmart the formula for the variance of a
uniform distribution but we can also do
it directly so the variance is the
expected value of the squared distance
from the mean so with probability 1/3
our random variable will take a value of
4 which is one unit apart from the mean
or more explicitly we have this term
with probability 1/3 our random variable
takes a value of 3 and with probability
1/3 our random variable takes the value
of 2
this term is 0 this is 1 times 1/3 from
here we get another 1 times 1/3 so
adding up we obtained that the variance
is 2/3
notice that the variance in the
conditional model is smaller than the
variance that we had in the original
model and this makes sense in the
conditional model there is less
uncertainty than there used to be in the
original model and this translates into
a reduction in the variance to conclude
there is nothing really different when
we deal with conditional pmfs
conditional expectations and conditional
variances they're just like the ordinary
pmf's expectations and variances except
that we have to use the conditional
probabilities throughout instead of the
original probabilities